[Music]
the fight for gender equality
has become a fight for life in
Afghanistan
since the Taliban regained control of
the country almost a year and a half ago
authoritarian rule has become the norm
with little to no space for women in
public life
so when in private Defiance comes in the
form of a pen and paper for these
teenagers education is an act of
resistance
and leading at the Forefront 5 000 miles
away in Britain is diwakhan who's taken
matters into her own hands the first
word was in Islam and it means read
so how can a child read if you don't
allow them to go to school if you don't
allow them to education it's not allowed
it's not acceptable it's not
a woman or suffering very much not only
education from every right they are
suffering it's 20 million women we
cannot forget them we cannot let them in
the dark
Breaking Point has brought diwa and
other activists here with a letter for
the Prime Minister outlining plans for a
global Summit to ensure their people
aren't left behind Five foreign
secretaries in a row have committed to
this issue and it is time to hold that
leadership and that commitment to this
issue to account they live in absolutely
Draconian times it's it's like dark ages
in Afghanistan silent is complicit and
UK government shouldn't be silent
meanwhile back in Afghanistan the call
is welcome but for now they know their
situation stays the same
they are the future of Afghanistan if we
don't educate them what will happen
so it's good if there were more
opportunities to come to the UK but I
won't be joining them because I really
want to teach my own country's daughters
we want rights for women in Afghanistan
just like you have in the UK
have a shower every second there is a
threat if they find out there may be a
harsh punishment regardless we will
study and try to get somewhere but the
question is should they have to put
themselves at such risk
this reality for the young girls is not
normal they've only known life
pre-taliban they just want basic
Universal rights the same as you and me
and crucially not to be forgotten
Sky News